if you want to be Jurek hair designer
and are not so sure where to start this
is the video to help you to get your
foot into the door
the most important skill and knowledge
you need to have designed knowing how to
do 3d model and hence sketching is
understand how to 3d model for stone
setting properly and understand the
production process specially for stone
setting in jury design many of you know
me pj chain design channel you know my
teaching style and structure my name is
PJ Chiang I've been bench jeweler since
1999 that helped my cap model to be
production friendly I'm also teaching
medicine jury in the college for 15
years so I know how to deliver the
material to students on top of that I'm
an authorized rhino3d trainer with all
my expertise I would like to offer you a
course that's going to help you to level
up your jury design skill it is Rhino 6
jury stone setting 3d modeling course
this is a very practical course if you
are new designer to jewelry industry or
you just want to gain more knowledge for
stone setting in cat design I will show
you a step-by-step illustration of how
stone is set in the reality I will also
show you how to model different type of
a stone with Rhino 6 there will be a lot
of discussion on the design guideline
for 3d printing this course covered
bezel set prong set B set pave set micro
pave channel set flush setting hello and
cluster set this will be the most
comprehensive Rhino 6 stone setting 3d
modeling course that you can find on the
market if you are not sure this is the
right course for you check out the link
and preview part of the course for free
sign up the course now with first 100
student will have $50 off with coupon
code stone 50 thank you and see you
online